joining me here my colleague i guess
from nbc sports
i'm part of the nbc sports family i'll
be happy to say that um
and uh we've uh we've got peter king
back here on the rich eisen show how are
you pk
everything's going well rich how about
you what the hell was that last night
what was that
that's really that's the strangest
result of this season
easily but i think the the oddest
part was uh and again
uh in my opinion if tom brady gets
pressured like that
um he's they don't have a chance
so you know i i uh you know you've got
to ask bruce arians byron left which
they're
um you know the coaching staff
um about their protection for brady
and how that's going to get fixed if
that doesn't get fixed
uh the i the bucks will be won and out
in the one and done whatever the cliche
is in the playoffs
um but i think the other part of it that
was very odd to me
was i wrote a little bit about this
today
okay so on breeze's last touchdown pass
okay to heal the tight end
did you see what levante david did
in the end zone in that on that play
it's like
he had no idea where he was and he was
asking for help and he was motioning
with his hands
and then when the ball was snapped he
barely covered the tight end
it was just one of the that's one of the
strangest plays of the day
and that's that's supposed to be a top
three to five defense in the league
it was i don't know what to make of that
but
there is not a more there's not a
a a game in the nfl that set this season
that sets off alarm bells more for a
team and i include
uh the packers loss at tampa this was
the most alarming
game uh and and honestly rich
you know look the saints were fantastic
okay utterly fantastic but
that's what the saints do they play a
thousand guys on offense
you have no idea how many guys they're
shuffling in and out of the lineup
11 different guys catching a pass in the
first 20 minutes of the game
and before you know it it's 21 nothing
that's the saints now
they can't always do that but that's the
saints of their peak
so that really didn't shock me to be
honest what shocked me
is the deficiencies on the offensive
line of tampa and on defense
yeah i mean you know uh brees last night
um
was kind of asked the same question i
asked you like what what happened there
and breeze's response was something
similar in fact like i don't know that
they had all their guys too
and he got all his guys back and he got
he got the you know
arguably the best receiver in the league
back last night i mean what a difference
maker and just in terms of
uh coverage needing to respect him his
nobody
nobody goes over the middle like him uh
uh on that roster
um and presents uh a target for drew
brees quite like that
and then that's what opens everything
else up whether
it's taysom hill or adam troutman you
know i mean that
that's and then you got a master at the
controls
uh in a headset on the sideline and in a
helmet on the field i mean that's what
makes this team so difficult
peter you know i wrote about the adam
troutman touchdown in my column today
and that the reason i wrote about it
is that when the play happened
i looked at who was on the field
for uh new orleans okay now left to
right
okay michael thomas was wide receiver
split left
in the left slot was jared cook
you know the big tight end yes and then
you had adam troutman the rookie tight
end
uh from university of dayton uh tight to
the formation on the right
and then they had their fullback okay
mike
burton uh split out
wide right so the wide receivers who
hurt
were michael thomas and mike burton who
i don't even think mike mike burton is a
household name in his own household
and and and he's this short kind of
chunky
guy and he's out there at wide receivers
so
everybody you know why sean payton does
that
because now everybody thinks that he's
going to pick either jared cook
you know to the left or he's going to
play a
throw a fade to michael thomas so what
does he do
he locks his eyes onto jared cook and
then at the last moment
just quickly swivels back to the inside
and he hits adam troutman
in the end zone for a touchdown and
again it's so obvious you think well
you know they're never no one would ever
expect us to go to adam troutman or mike
burton
and then that's where they go and i i
don't know to me
i just think sean payton in so many ways
is playing chess while everybody else is
playing checkers i
he's such a smart not only play designer
and play caller
but people utilize her
you know that's that's what really makes
him good and people
motivate her because mike burton is also
the
name of the first guy in jameis
winston's career
who he hit with a pass that didn't play
for the buccaneers to jameis's benefit
he's the only guy that winston connected
with
last night when he came on he came
on and you know like what that meant for
jameis and you know
again at some point you know at some
point
brees would have to be taken out of the
game um
but you know jameis has eaten and
and and and getting into breezes uh
post-game chat it was all just as good
in that hood as
possible do you think this is
indicative of the next half of this
season
peter you know
i've it's through football history
especially with teams
that you think man that's
uncharacteristic you know what rich
it usually is you know so
i would be surprised if tampa
uh going forward um
you know basically is as bad
they'll figure a way to go to carolina
and play better now
to me as i said my column today i mean
going to carolina that's i it's a weird
thing to say but that's going to be a
herculean task
to beat the panthers you know if if if
um you know if christian mccaffrey is in
the game
we don't know now if he is with that
added shoulder injury from yesterday
but the carolina panthers are a
load and my feeling is
look i got a lot of guys who i'm going
to put on my coach of the year list
you know mike tomlin brian flurries are
probably
right at the top in some some order
but i'll tell you one thing matt rule's
gonna be up there
um how in the world when you
totally rebuild your organization do you
go to kansas city
kansas city with that offense playing
as well almost as well as you've ever
seen it
i just i i was so impressed with
not just the effort everybody says oh
great effort by metro
they've built a good team rich you know
and a lot of those guys are there for
the first time
i mean don't you think joe douglas is
sick watching robbie anderson play the
way he is
he's a number one receiver and they got
him for 10 million a year
you know the jets could have had him a
long time ago
for 10 million a year and it's just i i
mean
that is a smart organization with a good
guy running it
don't get me started because i got to
watch a jets game tonight and then talk
about it tomorrow uh here on the rich
show peter king here hey they might win
that game you never know hey look what
the weird year
well this was as i i started the show
peter by saying that the any given
sunday yesterday was one of those given
sundays
based on everything else that we saw um
so uh what what do you what can you take
out of yesterday that you think is again
indicative of the second half of the
season i'm i'm still waiting for
somebody and i know
steelers fans might be like hey we're
eight no for the first time ever
to separate to separate here maybe the
saints did last night
anything and i i would even include tua
as well the dolphins have won
four in a row for the first time in four
years the bills appear to have gotten
their
their ship straightened out a little bit
while seattle's defense really got beat
up
yesterday and for the first time all
year the offense wasn't able to counter
so what about yesterday do you think can
be indicative
over the next eight weeks
yeah well you know the dolphins to me
are
a legitimate very serious threat
to buffalo at the top of the division
not only have they won four in a row
but they won them by 26 24 11 and
yesterday a
tough tough road game uh
at arizona with the miracle man kyler
murray and they win that
uh you know only by three but you're
right
i i think the three headlines of
yesterday
in my opinion okay number one the miami
dolphins are making the playoffs
i i don't i don't know if they're
winning the division or whatever
the miami dolphins are gonna make the
playoffs that's number one
uh number two um
i think the minnesota vikings are not
dead okay i think
they're definitely on life support
because
you know at three and five you need a
lot of things to go right
but what they have figured the last two
weeks is
let's give uh let's give dalvin cook
30 touches a week and let's limit kirk
cousins
to 20 passes a week and and look they
can
however you want to phrase it whatever
you want to say that is a better offense
when it's in the hands of dalvin cook
and quite honestly
alexander madison who is dalvin cook jr
i mean i think he's one of the two three
whatever best
backup running backs in football and my
third observation would be
we are living in a time of
the next truly great player who
and again look you have no idea what the
future holds
but as i wrote my column this morning
you know patrick mahomes
at the age he is this morning has 101
touchdown passes
drew brees at that same age had 29 and
tom brady had 27.
and so we have to acknowledge right now
that we could be watching uh
really a michael jordan type player
and it's amazing how good he is
and he's just basically in his nfl
infancy
well again the uh the the i guess
best testament to mahomes's remarkable
talent and success and
um efficiency and
i guess what other word can you possibly
use other
than intense
love that people have for him the
best measure of it peter is that we have
already at age 25 reached the part of
his career where why give him the mvp
i mean you know you know what i mean
like we've already reached that point
of the why give belichick coach the year
why would we give phil jackson coach of
the year i mean the guy
it's it's already stipulated he's
most valuable so let's let's spread it
around
the kid's only 25 peter i mean he is the
mvp
of the league the mvp is you know rich
the mvp is so weird because
you know if you had if we had been
talking 24 hours ago
i would have said to me there's there's
some great candidates but i mean russell
wilson
i believe has done the most
uh with a supporting cast that's good
but not great
uh into i i don't when i say supporting
cast i mean
53 men on his roster right you know i
i have great appreciation for those
offensive weapons i think they're
fantastic
but i also think that it's not far and
away
the best team and they might be the best
team in football but
but you know i just think that russell
wilson
is doing an awful lot with the people
who he's working with
but then so in one three hour period
it all flips and that's why to me
whenever we do the mvp which as i've
railed against for years
i think it's a mistake that we only get
to vote for
one person for mvp it's wrong
because baseball does it so much better
where you vote
on a sliding scale so that you could say
let's just say for the sake of argument
at the end
that uh that russell wilson trimmed
uh patrick mahomes and ben
roethlisberger or whoever for
the mvp award you won't have any idea
who he trimmed
because there's only one vote i just i'm
not crazy about it but
the the the thing that i always try to
keep in mind about
the mvp is that it's a 17 week award
and everybody just start everybody like
this morning will say well you got to
give it to my home
maybe you do let's see what happens
because it's a 17 week award
no doubt uh peter king last one for you
ask him the poll question before we send
him out the door we've got
uh again uh cam jordan coming up in
about four minutes time here on the rich
eisen show go for it chris
peter who's the best team in the nfl
steelers chiefs bills
saints
um
at this moment i will say the steelers
because i trust their defense more than
i trust kansas city's defense
and i think they can score enough to
beat kansas city
but it won't surprise me if my answer in
two weeks is kansas city
i think they're both terrific and i
think those two teams right now
um at least today if i see one or two
more of those games by new orleans
well new orleans is going to go in there
in that category
and to me the one other thing i would
say you have buffalo in there
look buffalo's won three in a row but
only one of them is against a really
good team in seattle
and you know i just i've got not
vivid but it's not that far far
gone uh that the tennessee that
tennessee and kansas city
both handled them and that uh the first
month josh allen uh devolved into
2018 josh allen well yesterday josh
allen was back to being september josh
you know so let's see where he is when
they go to arizona on sunday
that's right that's a big game arizona
on sunday and miami's next games
uh at denver the chargers the jets and
joe boro before kansas city i mean
it's just going to be the tua train has
left the station
and it's going to be must-see every
single week and
i know you chose miami so fun to watch
yesterday oh my
the last thing i'll say because i know
you got to go but you know my first
reaction when i was watching that game
and flipping back and forth
between that and pittsburgh pittsburgh
dallas which was really a fun game too
my first thought was are you serious
that we will not see tua vs kyler murray
again
four years until the 2024
presidential campaign is hot and heavy
it's insane
how in the world can the nfl give us tua
versus kyler murray once every four
years
that's got to change this 17th game rich
you have your ball fumbled out of the
back of the end zone as the thing
that has to be fixed about the nfl my
thing that has to be fixed
that 17th game starting next year
has to be in howard katz's lap and
howard katz
every march has to look at
great match-ups that we could find for
that 17th game
and i will take tyler murray and uh
and tuataga veloa every other year oh my
gosh uh
and and and in honor of one other thing
i'll take two of her 200 alex
that's that's right yes who is peter
king and what is
the football morning in america must
read stuff thanks again for the call
peter
all the best rich you take care you got
it that's peter king